Lucan ate here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and we're celebrating
100 thousand subscribers and to do that
we're taking these aluminum foil balls
and melting them down and making silver
play button belt buckles and we want you
guys to celebrate too so at the end of
this video we're gonna be giving away
one of these silver play button belt
buckles and belt
to one of you guys you excited need
let's do it
what's our motto here at the outdoor
boys YouTube channel we don't know what
we're doing but we're excited to do it I
am gonna be casting some aluminum to
make belt buckles for me and the boys
and I have never done this before
first I've got to make a little box to
hold all my forming sand and I need to
make a wooden replica of the belt buckle
I want to make so we're to get started
with that
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well there we go not looking too shabby
huh well I'm losing my sunlight so I'm
gonna let this dry and pick this up
tomorrow morning well guys it's another
beautiful day and I am ready to get
going this is dried up very nicely and
in case you're wondering I painted it to
try to smooth it out and to master the
grain pattern I didn't want the grain
pattern transferring to the aluminum
I've got a bunch of aluminum left over
for my tinfoil ball videos but I'm not
quite sure it's gonna be enough to make
belt buckles for all of us so I've also
got this piece of aluminum stock that
I'm not using then I'm gonna chop up
shove it in the crucible as well and
cross our fingers that should be enough
little bit soft I think we need to
compact that a little bit more
they didn't work so well
[Music]
oh is that as good as I've done so they
sprayed this with wd-40 that seemed to
help all right we finally got it I think
we can actually go ahead and try this
one all right so this is all the
aluminum I have and we're going to just
start chucking it in there and seeing
what we can melt seems like a bit and
that let's start off with that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that looks pretty darn good I'm pretty
pleased with that haha nailed it that
was a lot easier but you notice I've got
a little bit of sand it's falling in
there just take a can of compressed air
just gently blow that sucker out there
we go
[Music]
[Applause]
well this one's not too bad but it's way
too thick and it's got all this
blackened sand around it think I think I
could do better
[Music]
that's awesome
yeah that one turned out really good
nice and smooth good crisp detail not
too thick well now I'm gonna go to the
hardware store and see if I can find
some screws some little brass screws
they'll allow me to put this belt buckle
Hardware on the back of my silver play
buttons all right guys I went to the
hardware store and picked up some more
aluminum so I'm gonna cast some more
belt buckles here but I am also got some
brass screws teeny little guy to attach
the hardware to screw it to the back of
the belt the buckles but I was thinking
about it I might be doing this the hard
way so I'm also gonna take a piece of
this 3/16 inch steel and bend it make my
own hardware which I might be able to
insert into the molten aluminum when I
cast it so we're gonna try a couple
different ways to make these buckles and
see what happens and hopefully if it
works we'll have an extra one or two to
give away to you guys as a giveaway
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
not too thick got the hardware already
installed not bad at all that worked out
real well
that thing is thick it's like a bar so
that's cool-looking though
so what do you think babe you know it's
really cool-looking and it's it's
heavier than I would have think aluminum
would be yeah it's a there's a pretty
good chunk of aluminum it's it's pretty
good big and it's got some steel though
yeah cool
well there we go
looks pretty good but you can see this
kind of off-color right there and there
that's the steel resting on the bottom
so yeah that's gonna cause a little
problems but it looks pretty cool still
all right guys I've got 8 play buttons
here three of them already have the
hardware in them too I'm gonna put
hardware in them and the other three
well I'm gonna do something with them
but I'm running out of daylight here
I'll pick this up again a little bit
well it's another beautiful day and I
have a few minutes so I'm gonna try to
get the hardware mounted on the back of
these belt buckles and a few of them
I've noticed are just really
unpleasantly thick I mean the belt
buckle shouldn't be like a bar of soap
strapped to your waist so I think I
might take the angle grinder and really
try to remove a lot of metal off the
back of a few of these and we shall see
what happens
there we go got a lot thinner what well
I've been trying repeatedly to put these
screws into the aluminum and you've got
to get the pilot hold just right
otherwise it puts too much pressure on
the screws and breaks them right in half
I broke four screws and a half trying to
get this right but I think I finally got
it dialed down and we're gonna give it
another go all right I've got the belt
buckles done I've got the harness
leather now let's make some bells
[Music]
[Music]
well there we go silver play button belt
buckle nice it's beautiful
which belt buckle do you want huh you
want this one which one do you want
Nathan oh you I do it that's a cool one
we need to make belts to go with your
belt buckles this one's gonna be Tommy
so hold your arms up in the air puts it
about like
[Music]
[Music]
well it ain't pretty
there it is outdoor boys well look at
that there we go you got a bunch of
awesome belts here for the outdoor boys
and a few extra to give away as prizes
so I am really super happy with how
these turned out should we go try them
on
well guys do you like your belt yeah
yeah you're cowboys well you look great
what you doing there Nathan now the
person who deserves one of these silver
play buttons more than any of us is mama
take a look at that one's for you thank
you you look at the back well it is late
and I gotta get these Cowboys to bed and
I'm still gonna show you guys how you
can win some of these belt buckles we're
doing an awesome giveaway that is
actually really cool-looking uh-huh like
that buddy
all right go to preschool you're ready
to get a free skill heck yeah he needs
it what you got there ha oh let me see
your belt there yeah that's a pretty
slick belt buddy all right guys I told
you that I was gonna give away this belt
buckle and belt I'm gonna do just that
if you want to win this aluminum belt
buckle made from our first aluminum foil
ball all you have to do is these three
things one make sure you're subscribed
only subscribers can win so click
subscribe folks to leave a comment
telling me your favorite type of outdoor
boys video whether it's camping survival
foraging goofing around with Tommy and
Navy logs tell me what your favorite
type of video is and 3 make sure you
share this video on any social media
platform whether it's YouTube Facebook
Instagram whatever so if you do those
three things you'll be entered to win
and I'll announce the winner one week
from today in my next video so good luck
to everybody well thanks for watching
guys and we hope you enjoyed this video
make sure you check some of our awesome
video playlists thanks for watching we
hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you'd like to see more great videos from
the outdoor boys youtube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every week and don't forget to
hit that Bell button so you'll get
notified when we put out another great
video